شركه ابل تتبع قانون البلد الذي تعمل فيه
وهذا تعهد للرئيس التنفيذي للشركه تم كوك
الان بات مطالب بالتنفيذ تحديدا في دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي معركه الون ماسك مع افل
انتقلت من امريكا الى اوروبا ومن نفس
الفكره الرغبه في الغاء الاحتكار وهنا
ياتي القانون الاوروبي الجديد للاسواق
الرقميه وبالمناسبه واشنطن ايضا تقترح
تشريعا مشابها يناقش في الكونغرس حاليا
ابل ستور وهو متجر ابل الذي يدير عليها
المليارات في اوروبا تحديدا 29 مليارا من
اصل 95 حققتها في هذا العام في دول
الاتحاد اتت من المتجر 30% هي عموله افل
على المشتريات من ابل ستور سياسا فقدها
الكثيرون مالك ايفون لا يمكنك تنزيل اي
تطبيق الا من خلال هذا المتجر لكن وفق
القانون الجديد على قفل الان السماح
بالتنزيلات المباشره من متاجر بديله او
التحميل الجانبي للتطبيقات من الويب كما
يحدث في اجهزه اندرويد لا خيار بديل الان
امام الشركه الرفض يعني غرامه اوروبيه تصل
الى 20% من ايرادتها السنويه نتحدث تقريبا
عن 80 مليار من اصل 400 مليار حققتها هذا
العام اما ما اثر الوقت
الامتثال لجميع بنود القانون سيكون بدءا
من 2024 رغم انه سيدخل حيز التنفي
2023 لكن ابل لا تلعب ورقه الوقت سلام
ورقه اخرى تجاوز متجر ابل ستور ويعرض
المستخدمين يعرض المستخدمين لمخاطر الامن
والخصوصيه وهذه كلمات المطورين
مهمه لا يريد اي مستخدم طبعا فقدان هذه
الميزه ولو كلفه اموالا اضافيه المنافسه
صعبه اذا ولهذا السبب تتوقع مؤسسه سي اف
ار ان الابحاث تاثر اقل من 0.2% فقط من
اجماليات مبيعات ابل